[MUSIC PLAYING]
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
I really live to teach.
It is my greatest joy,
and meeting those students
and working with
those students is
what is most meaningful to me.
University of Arizona
distinguished professor
Melissa Fitch brings
an infectious level
of energy and creativity
to her classroom
in the College of Humanities.
I want them to feel really
excited about this-- oh wow,
OK, we're learning this.
An author and recipient
of three Fulbright Awards,
in 2008, she received
the University
of Arizona's Five Star Teaching
Award, the institution's
highest teaching honor.
In 2013, she received the
Creative Teaching Award.
And in 2015, she was named one
of three university-wide 1885
Society Distinguished
Fellows based
on her research,
teaching, and service.
She's probably one of our
best recruiters with students.
Students are really in
love with her classes,
with the topics that she offers.
A lot of students who
take Dr. Fitch's class
want to take more classes
from Dr. Fitch afterwards.
We've seen a lot in terms of
the flipped classrooms, how
we're going to engage students
in a more creative manner.
It kind of feels like she's
been doing that from the get-go,
just because she wants to
engage with the person--
When I am doing a
lecture-focused session,
I intentionally am stopping
every 10 or 15 minutes,
and I'm saying,
now, you're going
to have to talk to
this person about what
we're looking at here.
Now I want you to analyze
this, and I want you to do--
so they have to get
out of that little daze
that they tend to be in.
It was never part of my
plan to be in academia,
by any stretch of
the imagination.
I had studied in Mexico, and
then I had studied in Spain,
and got my undergraduate degree.
And honestly, I didn't know
what I was going to do,
and I wanted, desperately,
to get back to the border.
As someone who's
bicultural, bilingual,
half Mexican, half
Anglo, I really
am only comfortable,
to be honest
with you, in the border region.
She signed on as a founding
faculty member of the Arizona
International campus at
the University of Arizona
and then a faculty member in
the College of Humanities,
where she's a specialist in
Latin American popular culture.
And one of the things
I try to teach students
is that the way that we learn
about people of other cultures
or countries is not particularly
innocent-- that, in fact,
there are some ideological
assumptions that we can tease
out, and that we
can see, and it's
important to be able to
question a lot of the ideas
that we assume are natural,
or normal, or whatnot.
Her love of the tango
began in Argentina,
where she enrolled
in a class on a whim
and was inspired by
her first instructor.
I had never taken a dance class
of any kind in my entire life,
and at the end of the hour,
I asked her what she thought,
and she said that
there was no hope.
You know, frankly, she
was absolutely right.
And so when she
got to the end, I
said, well, so I guess
I'll see you tomorrow.
[APPLAUSE]